[Musique]
bonjour à tous les entretiens politiques
avec pierre bédier bonsoir bonsoir
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines mais aussi président de la
fédération les républicains des yvelines
alors revenons sur l'actualité les
élections présidentielles 2022 le
président de la république emmanuel
macron a été réélu avec 58 % des
suffrages au niveau national quand on
regarde dans les yvelines il arrive
largement en tête avec 71 % des voix
mais c'est moins bien qu'en 2017
puisqu'il était à 77%
votre regard sur ce score c'est vrai que
c'est moins bien mais enfin 71 % c'est
quand même pas mal beaucoup de candidats
aimerais faire ça au deuxième tour
ensuite c'est un peu logique qu'un
tassement il a quand même un bilan même
si la campagne électorale n'a pas pu
examiner cet cet aspect là mais bon
voilà en tout cas c'est une victoire
nette et il est en tête dans tous les
cantons il est en tête dans toutes les
circonscriptions législatives
pas dans toutes les communes une
douzaine de communes ont préféré choisir
madame le pen mais ce sont des communes
d'une taille modeste enfin quand je
parle de taille modeste je veux dire du
nombre d'habitants donc
incontestablement monsieur macron a
rencontré la faveur des yvelinois et
finalement les yvelines c'est un peu une
mini france puisque quand on regarde les
résultats dans le détail et les grandes
villes ont voté pour emmanuel macron et
finalement les zones rurales péri
urbaines ont voté pour le rassemblement
national il ya peu de surf c'est en
termes économiques en terme de paysage
est uni france en termes politiques
c'est une mini france un peu amplifié
vous l'avez vous même d'ailleurs noté
58% plan national 71% dans les yvelines
pour le président macron qui à 13 %
quand même de différence c'est pas une
petite chose c'est un département de
grande modération des yvelines on n'aime
pas les excès et le corps électoral les
habitants
ce sont des gens modérés qui aiment
qu'on leur présente les choses de façon
modérée et intelligent néanmoins marine
le pen fait quand même une percée dans
le département 40 mille voix
supplémentaires par rapport à 2010 est
le rassemblement national s'installe
petit à petit de dans les yvelines ça
dépend des élections
il ya eu des moments où le front
national qui était son ancêtre a connu
des pics des moments où il a connu des
chutes en fonction des éternels bagarre
qui marquent l'histoire de l'extrême
droite alors c'est vrai que l'extrême
droite là pour une fois s'est divisée
enfin pour une fois c'est diviser une
fois de plus mais ça n'a pas eu d'impact
au contraire ça fait grossir leur leur
magot électorale mais bon j'en ai pas
encore le moment de dire écoutez le son
me semble-t-il même si l'accroissement
de voix de madame le pen ne me surprend
pas c'est vrai que il ya quand même pour
bon nombre de nos concitoyens des
préoccupations importantes de vies
quotidiennes le département qui gère les
différentes aides sociales voit bien que
la vie est vraiment dure pour un grand
nombre de nos concitoyens les yvelinois
sont plutôt convaincu par les idées du
rassemblement national ou plutôt son
c'est un vote de colère de contestation
je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de colère et
un peu de convaincu je ne crois pas
pas plus dans les yvelines qu'en france
à l'extrémisme je pense que il ya une
certaine désespérance
devant une politique qui n'écoute pas ce
que ressentent les gens les plus
modestes ceux qu'on appelle les
catégories populaires et c'est cette
colère qui s'exprime
il ya une espèce de deux ruptures 1
entre le haut le bras les élus et le
peuple alors y'a pas que les élites qui
ont voté pour monsieur macron autrement
il n'aurait pas fait 71 % mais on voit
bien cette désespérance et qui donc
exprime ce vote de désespoir parce que
madame le pen en aucun cas ne peut être
un vote d'espoir ces propositions elle a
beau les édulcorer élection après
élection
on voit bien que c'est pas très réaliste
un mot sur versailles et après on en
aura terminé avec le rassemblement
national versailles au premier tour mais
en seconde position eric zemmour au
deuxième tour marine le pen fait 30%
votre regard sur la ville de versailles
c'est quoi c'est les idées nationalistes
conservatrice qui qu'ils y sont
qui prévalent chez les versaillais non
puisque emmanuel macron les majoritaires
à versailles comme dans les autres
grandes villes mais c'est vrai qu'une
des caractéristiques de la droite
versaillaise c'est que il ya toujours
une droite extrême sans être forcément
apparenté au front national ou au
rassemblement national elle était il y
avait un monsieur qui s'appelait de les
scans qui à une époque faisait aussi des
scores assez substantielle aux élections
municipales et en faire nos élections
locales versaillaise qu'elle soit ou
local ou national je m'explique mal
pardon et
je crois qu'il ya une tradition
versaillaise autour d'eux sort
c'est chacune de nos communes a ses
spécificités
c'est celle de versailles revenons sur
le premier tour peu après 20 heures même
avant que votre candidate ne s'exprime
vous twittez et vous l'annoncer vous
votre et emmanuel macron au second tour
vous ferez barrage au front national au
rassemblement national c'est tout
naturel c'était naturel pour vous c'est
le combat de ma vie donc ça pour moi ça
ne se discute pas les
des yvelinois savez s'ils ne le savent
pas j'en profite pour leur dire moi je
je suis un enfant
de la vème république je suis un enfant
du gaullisme j'ai une fidélité absolue
pour jacques chirac ma carrière
politique carrière et le mot à utiliser
elle et elle est née ici à
mantes-la-jolie contre l'extrémisme de
droite parce qu'il n'est pas la solution
aux maux du pays les maux du pays sont
réels mais on ne trouvera pas la réponse
dans l'extrémisme et certainement pas
dans cet extrémisme là qui divise la
communauté nationale je crois que la
nation dans toute sa diversité peut se
rassembler pour autant que on ne désigne
pas les bons les méchants les mauvais et
c est donc ça passait totalement naturel
le poursuivre tout le sens de ma vie
politique en étant tout de suite contre
cet extrémisme qui encore une fois abîme
la france pourtant ça fait débat quand
même au sein de votre parti puisqu'il ya
certaines figures certains élus les
républicains qui ont préféré voter blanc
s'abstenir
peut-être même voter marine le pen votre
regard sur sas et je n'ai entendu aucun
de mes amis politiques et aucun des
responsables de ma formation politique
dire qu'ils voteraient marine le pen un
certain nombre ont exprimé leur volonté
de ne pas choisir je ne suis pas
d'accord avec eux c'est après la la vie
politique c'est pas parce qu'on a des
désaccords qu'on ne peut pas s'accorder
sur des sujets aussi de grande
importance mais vous dites que c'est
alors je dis c'est pas un désaccord
fondamental quand même pas ce que vous
dites que votre combat politique quand
même s'est inscrite contrôleur c'est ce
qui serait le désaccord et est
fondamental avec le front national
rassemblement national le désaccord avec
mes amis c'est sur la façon de combattre
ça eux considèrent que la meilleure
façon de combattre
l'extrémisme de droite
l'extrême droite c'est de ne pas faire
la part trop belle à monsieur macro moi
je considère que la question dans ces
moments là n'est pas monsieur macron la
question c'est celle de l'extrême droite
et il faut pas se poser de questions
votre candidate pour le parti
républicain valérie pécresse arrive à la
cinquième place avec moins de 5 % au
niveau national dans les yvelines c'est
la même position avec un peu plus de 8%
comment vous expliquer cette défaite
même sur son territoire
d'abord c'est pas son territoire valérie
et la présidente du conseil régional
d'île de france et fait un score un peu
supérieurs d'ile-de-france sa marine
nationale bon c'est incontestablement un
échec
elle ressent probablement je n'ai pas
échangé avec elle comme tel pour elle
mais c'est aussi plus globalement notre
échec et la fin d'un cycle je crois que
il faut qu'on remette à plat un certain
nombre d'idées
la façon d exprimer j'ai eu l'occasion
de dire à d'autres médias dans cette
campagne pardonnez moi j'espère que les
enfants ne nous regarde pas je vais
utiliser un gros mot je nous ai trouvés
chiant
pas d'idées nouvelles pas d'aspérités en
train de
sa marque et de vie tout ça et je crois
que pour mener une campagne
présidentielle il faut à la fois parler
bien sûr le langage de la raison et par
les programmes il faut aussi parler le
langage du coeur il faut se lâcher il
faut il faut faire rêver les français et
leur donner envie de se dépasser ce pays
manque de ça
les français sont sensibles à la
grandeur mauricienne amoureux de rugby
quand on voit ce que cette bande de
gamins nous a donné comme émotions
pendant ce tournoi des six nations
c'était extraordinaire
et on voyait bien que tout d'un coup les
français qui s'étaient désintéressés des
matchs de rugby s'en remettait à
regarder ça nous on aime le panache on
aime l'ambition
une forme de joie de vivre aussi je
pense que ça a manqué il faut que la
droite ne soit pas une droite punitive
je pense qu'il faut qu'on soit une
droite explicative et une droite assumé
nous commettons une erreur de diagnostic
j'entends partout les idées de droite
sont majoritaires totalement sous les
idées de droite ne sont pas qu'autour de
l'autorité du besoin d'autorité l'idée
centrale de la mode c'est la liberté
quand mes enfants me demandait c'est
quoi la différence entre la droite et la
gauche je leur disais lorsque j'étais
enfant après mon sophistique la liberté
plutôt de droite et d'égalité plutôt de
gauche l'aspiration à l'égalité des
français est bien plus importante
qu'elle oui mais quelle place y rast sur
la liberté parce qu'aujourd'hui celui
qui incarne la liberté c'est emmanuel
macron il faut expliquer aux français
que c'est à nous que monsieur macron
prétend nous donner de la liberté milk
nous en donne pas et que nous notre
objectif c'est la liberté d'entreprendre
la liberté d'assumer sa sa vie
individuelle la liberté individuelle
c'est cette liberté là qui nous
protègera on n'est plus protégé par la
liberté que par l'égalité car je
comprends bien dans ce monde troublé que
les français ce besoin de protection
bien il vaut mieux plus de liberté que
plus d'égalité pour répondre à ce besoin
de protection et sa cette philosophie là
je pense qu'elle nous a manqué il faut
accepter d'être en rupture peut-être
qu'il eût fallu d'ailleurs assumé dès le
début qu'on ne gagnerait pas mais qu' on
aurait une une grille de lecture
extrêmement simple extrêmement
compréhensible et qui se prépare à
construire la méga l'espace politique
encore pour ce combat pour la liberté
individuelle la liberté d'entreprendre
basse il n'y a pas cet espace un jeu
plus rien à faire en politique deux jeux
devant une sculpture à faire en france
la liberté c'est quand même quelque
chose de formidable
j'ai des amis j'ai même des amis
étrangers qui quand il d'origine
étrangère qui quand ils reviennent en
france meuse ils reviennent de leur pays
d'origine isabelle quand on est en
france dès qu'on arrive à l'aéroport on
a un sentiment de liberté parfois
excessif parce que nous sommes un peuple
un peu indisciplinés mais moi je crois
que cette aspiration à la liberté elle
est noble et qu'il nous faut la remettre
au centre du débat politique telle que
la droite le comptoir une suggestion
peut être
l'avenir des républicains aujourd'hui
quand on voit la majorité départementale
dans les yvelines un large rassemblement
que vous avez réussi à faire il ya des
élus d'horizon il ya des élus du modem
de l'udps et y ait des républicains est
ce que c'est c'est pas un modèle
justement pour recomposer le parti des
républicains est ce que vous n'êtes pas
un modèle pour cette recomposition
politique c'est très gentil à vous c'est
très flatteur mais je ne le pense pas en
tout cas je ne le crois pas
ce que nous essayons de le faire dans
les yvelines c'est d'amener
cherche que nous pensons être le socle
de bonne gestion qui permet par cette
bonne gestion ensuite d'avoir des
politiques généreuse vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens yvelinois et que c'est
peut-être un fils qui a été perdu dans
la gestion de la france avant d'être
généreux il faut être économe des
deniers publics pour se financer cette
générosité autrement que par de la dette
donc de ce point de vue je veux bien
qu'on soit exemplaire et mes
prédécesseurs l'été puisque je me suis
que l'héritier de ses surnoms politique
mais ce que nous avons réussi c'est à
amener tous les modérés tout ce que vous
avez cités sont des partis modérés sur
cette base de politiques et est ce que
on peut y arriver au plan national on
verra bien après tout je ne doute pas
que le présent macro est infiniment plus
de talent que moi donc c'est tout ce que
je souhaite mais permettez moi de ne pas
vouloir apparaître à cet instant de
notre échange comme vaniteux je déteste
la vanité en politique c'est clair pour
le parti des républicains il faut pas se
fondre avec les les alliés disons d'
emmanuel macron donc travaillé avec
horizon travail avec le modem sache
aussi dans les faits mais peut-être pas
au niveau national moi je pense qu'on
peut travailler tous ensemble ce que
j'appelle les modérés y compris en se
posant nous avons des débats entre nous
qui sont pas toujours public 1 mais avec
des débats de désaccord
et c'est légitime pour moi vraiment le
cercle c'est le cercle républicain ce
que vous avez cités il faut se méfier
ensuite
de ceux qui sont en dehors du cercle
républicain avec sa droite jeudi c'était
un combat mais l'extrême gauche aussi
parce que monsieur mélenchon est quand
même très loin des positions sociales
démocrates lé fils c'est pas le parti
socialiste de monsieur mitterrand on
l'oubli parce que monsieur mélenchon a
beaucoup de talent un grand talent
oratoire c'est un comédien
remarquable sa déclaration le soir du
premier tour était impressionnante pour
autant ces idées sont des idées de
vieille gauche c'est des idées qui n'ont
cours nulle part dans le monde à part
dans des pays parias qui se sont
transformés en pays basque parce qu'ils
ont voulu le socialisme dans un seul
pays ça finit toujours en dictature mais
on ne voit bien qu'il ya la jeunesse qui
est interpellé par certaines inégalités
par un monde qui va pas très bien
écologiquement détraqué
donc tout ça fait que lui aussi surf sur
ses peurs et il faut être vigilants sur
nos deux extrêmes et c'est ce qu'on a
voulu faire dans les yvelines c'est
ainsi qu'on est reconstitué cette
majorité
si ça peut servir pour la france comme
soyons encore une fois très très modeste
pas comme modèle mais comme inspiration
j'en serai très flatté très fier mais
pas plus voilà après les présidentielles
c'est le tour le troisième tour les
élections législatives comment ça
s'organise dans les yvelines vous qui
êtes président de la fédération je
rappelle des républicains dans les
yvelines une négociation d'abord avec
nos alliés traditionnels les centristes
donc ce sera l'union pour les yvelines
de la droite et du centre
cette union se fera dans les douze
circonscriptions les jce l'atvs et nous
enterrer une ronde donc mardi prochain
le 3 mai le nom des huit candidats qui
nous manque que je rappelle que nous
avons déjà choisi quatre candidats les
deux députés qui ont été élus dans la
présente mandature michel vialay dans la
circonscription de la jolie philippe
benassaya dans la circonscription de
trappes saint cyr l'école et l'encours
est la onzième que nous avions désigné
deux femmes une anne cabri dans la
circonscription de rambouillet et une
autre dans la circonscription de se
retrouver de maisons laffitte le vésinet
qui est donc alexandra d'une blanche et
nous allons désigner mardi prochain dès
l'es8 entre guillemets manquants il y
aura pas d'alliance il y aura pas il y
aura bien un candidat dans chaque
circonscription pour le party les
républicains l'union de la droite et du
centre oui parce que c'est ce que nous
demande notre formation politique l air
pour être tout à fait transparent avec
les yvelinois qui nous regardent je
n'étais pas sur cette ligne politique
moi je pense que ça n'est pas absurde ça
rejoint un peu ce qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure sur la majorité vit noise je
trouve que dans les grandes difficultés
que connaît la france ça ce n'est pas
absurde de travailler avec le président
réélu je dois dire que le fait qu'il
évoque le soir du premier tour un grand
parti unique a été avec tout le respect
qu'on doit à présent de la république et
mails en l'espèce il s'exprimait en
candidat nous très grande maladresse pas
ce que ça donnait un sentiment de
caporalisme qui correspond à aucun
moment au tempérament national
mais moi je pense qu'on a à faire des
choses ensemble alors on va les faire
différemment puisque la ligne qui a été
choisie est donc celle d'une opposition
mais ce sera en tout cas pour ce qu'on
veut dans les yvelines une opposition
constructive l'idée ce n'est pas de
s'opposer pour se poser on n'est pas des
mélenchonistes des lepénistes nous on
veut s'opposer à nos mandants pour
améliorer les réformes nécessaires pour
que la france aille mieux je leur
donnais un exemple nous sommes nous
convaincu nous avons défendu l'idée
qu'il fallait faire la retraite à 65 ans
pas parce que on veut à tout prix
embêter les français parce que tout
simplement la retraite il ya trois
critères
le niveau des cotisations tout le monde
est d'accord pour dire que on n'a pas
envie de descendre revenu sur n'augmente
les cotisations baisse de revenus le
niveau des pensions tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire qu'on n'a pas envie
de baisser les pensions non au contraire
envie qu'elle soit stable voire de les
augmenter donc il ya une troisième
paramètre ya pas 4 le troisième
paramètre c'est le moment où on part en
retraite comme l'espérance de vie
s'accroît il est assez logique que le
temps de travail puisse s'accroître nous
serons dans l'opposition constructive
les gardiens de cette volonté de passer
à 65 ans parce que j'ai cru comprendre
qu'entre les deux tours
monsieur macro on avait un peu vacillé
sur le sujet pour le premier tour à 65
ans pour le deuxième tour en revient
plutôt sur 62 bref mais il va quand même
falloir prendre en compte l'équilibré
budgétaire
l'argent ne tombe pas du ciel même si on
peut avoir eu ce sentiment pendant les
deux années qui viennent de s'écouler
mais la fête est finie on va vite ça en
beaugrand un mot très rapide dans la
circonscription de michel gallet la
huitième est ce qu'il n'ya pas un risque
avec les scores qu'on a vu au premier
tour à la fois de la france insoumise et
du rassemblement d'un soutiennent
entendu ça va être tout le combat de
michel de desserrer cet étau alors
michel a des qualités propres sa
notoriété d'une par l'excellence de son
travail dans les secteurs ruraux
il ya eu un gros scores sont nationales
je pense que les
les électeurs lui sont extrêmement
reconnaissants d'avoir empêché la
réalisation d'un projet de carrière
qu'ils allaient incontestablement
impacté négativement leur cadre de vie
je pense que sur la ville de mantes la
jolie où le mélenchonisme a triomphé 54%
au premier tour une bonne partie des
électeurs
se retourneront naturellement vers
michel vialay ils ont voulu envoyer un
signal nationale même si les élections
législatives et une élection nationale
elle a aussi une dimension humaine et
locales je pense que michel arrivera à
desserrer donc les les 2es les deux
mâchoires de l'étau mais oui un risque
dans la thématique de cette émission
vous nous accueillent ici dans votre
permanence à mantes la jolie et à
mantes-la-jolie il y aura une élection
municipale partielle le 15 mai et le 22
mai en cas de second tour un scrutin qui
fait suite aux divisions au sein de la
majorité le maire sortant se représente
d'ailleurs avec une liste et vous ne
serez pas à ses côtés puisque vous êtes
engagés dans la liste de son opposant
jean luc santini comment vous
appréhendez ce scrutin d'abord en fait
c'est le paradoxe et c'est le maire
sortant qui est l'opposant monsieur
santi dit puisque monsieur santini a
réuni autour de lui une majorité
municipale qui avait été lu en 2020 sur
un cap et qui s'est aperçu que le maire
ne faisait pas ce qu'il avait dit qu'on
allait faire donc ils se sont sentis
trahis ils ont surtout pensé que les
électeurs était trahi et c'est ce qui a
créé cette crise et jean-luc très
courageusement accepté
de porter le gant de ce qui avait été le
programme de 2020 et de façon d'ailleurs
très finalement très franche l'ancien
maire fait campagne sur un thème qui ait
changé de cap
bon mais il aurait dû le dire aux
électeurs il ya deux ans il aurait
surtout dû le dire à ses colistiers ça
nous aurait évité une crise dont nous
nous sommes la liste qui veut garder je
serai présent sur cette liste le cap le
cap qu'est ce que c'est c'est celui du
renouveau de la ville de mende qui est
largement engagée avec ce grand dossier
je suis depuis des années d'arrivée du
héros m qui va permettre une mutation
urbaine qui elle même a été très engagé
avec d'importantes réalisations dans le
quartier du val fourré beaucoup
d'innovations d'innovation sociale
d'innovation et éducative c'est ici
qu'on a fait un nouveau collège peu
révolutionnaire méthodes pédagogiques 1
et papa les enfants qui sont
révolutionnaires et et c'est cette envie
dont d'excellence cette ambition mais
cette ambition de cette excellence je
reviens à mes souci de bonne gestion
financés parce que dira on voit les
programmes de toutes les listes y
compris celle de l'ancien maire il ya
qu'à faut que oui mais avec quels sous
c'est toujours la même histoire et les
poches des électeurs les poches des
contribuables ne sont pas sans fond un
moment où ça s'arrête et donc nous nous
sommes la liste réaliste la liste
ambitieuse mais réalisme et ambition ce
sont les deux caractéristiques de la
liste que conduira jean-luc senti
puisque vous êtes engagés dans cette
liste deux projets phares que vous allez
défendre durant cette campagne buy
fondamentalement c'est la poursuite du
renouvellement urbain qui est absolument
indispensable cette ville a payé très
cher de grandes erreurs d'urbanisme dans
les années 60-70 en étant à peine en
train d'en sortir et ensuite c'est
l'ambition éducative
ici il ya beaucoup d'enfants issus de
familles migrantes et par l'ambition
éducative c'est ainsi qu'on permettra
une bonne intégration de ces familles au
fonctionnement de la société française
et bien entendu il n'ya pas que ces
enfants là tous les enfants bénéficient
mais c'est à la fois le moyen d'assurer
ce cette union dont nous avons besoin
cette union à l'internât nations et
aussi de faire que tous les enfants
demandent quelles que soient leurs
origines puissent accéder aux meilleures
études et les meilleures études c'est
pas une condition suffisante mais c'est
une condition nécessaire pour
espérer prendre l'ascenseur social ce
qui je crois est l'ambition pas des
enfants des parents de ces enfants
élections municipales partielles le 15
mai prochain les électeurs de menthe
sont appelés aux urnes pour élire le
nouveau conseil municipal les autres
candidats la liste de l'ex maire raphaël
cogné deux listes à gauche menée par
guillaume quévarec et le communiste marc
jamais une liste et les rues même piloté
par françois gerber et la liste lutte
ouvrière de thierry gonot merci pierre
bédier merci à vous président du conseil
départemental des yvelines et président
de la fédération les républicains mais
j'espère bientôt conseiller municipal de
montage et
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi un
entretien politique à retrouver sur
notre site internet ou sur l'application
mobile à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
oh